facebook's oversight board has upheld
the decision to suspend
former u.s president donald trump let's
go straight to our u.s correspondent
mark stone um mark what have they said
this has just come in the last couple of
minutes
yes uh just uh four minutes or so ago a
decision by the oversight board
um who operate uh funded by facebook but
an independent oversight
uh uh oversight board it should be
stressed uh we're asked to look into the
decision or asked indeed
by donald trump and his team uh to look
into the decision
to ban him from facebook a decision that
was made by facebook's chief executive
uh on january the sixth as a consequence
of numerous um tweet
numerous posts on facebook that he had
made over the course of
of several months but at what amounted
to a moment on january the sixth when
we all remember what happened uh on
capitol hill here with um
uh the insurrection there at so-called
uh
donald trump uh asked for a a review the
review has taken place and the board has
upheld facebook's decision so
for the time being donald trump will
remain off
facebook that will include of course
instagram which is owned by
facebook he is already banned from
twitter
um now what difference will this make
well clearly um
you know every day i get some uh press
releases from donald trump's team
press releases which resemble the tweets
that we that we remember
from last year he is clearly a man
frustrated that he is not able to
to use social media in a way that he
once was able to
um that for the time being at least will
be the case certainly
with facebook and instagram but those
press releases show that this is a man
who still has a message to get out there
and remember that half the country
almost 47 74 million people voted for
donald trump
he believes they still want to hear from
him he wants that message out there and
he's in the process we're told of trying
to set up his own social media
platform so yes had this decision been
reversed and it's worth stressing that
the first four decisions that this
independent oversight board
had to make on other other cases they
did in in those instances decide to
reverse facebook's decision
in this case they have not um but you
know
had they over overturned this he would
have had that platform which would have
been a help to him
they have decided to uphold facebook's
decision but he is still attempting to
get his message out there he is no
longer the president
he still has many followers